ararat el mítico monte en el que según
la tradición bíblica se posó el arca de
noé tras el diluvio universal
este monte aparece dentro de los límites
de turquía pero siempre formó parte de
la armenia histórica y hasta en 1915 sus
faldas estaban habitadas en su mayoría
por población armenia desde entonces
este volcán inactivo se convirtió para
el país en un símbolo del genocidio de
15 millones de armenios a manos de las
tropas otomanas en su afán de crear un
estado homogéneo formado solo por
población turco humana tras la pérdida
de nagorno karabaj en la reciente guerra
contra azerbaiyán este 106 aniversario
tiene un significado especial para los
armenios de todo el mundo
como armenia francesa en la diáspora ha
sido muy importante para mí estar aquí
este 24 de abril hoy ha sido un año muy
duro para armenio los armenios y la
diáspora armenia que actualmente viven
en torno a 3 millones de personas en el
país pero se calcula que la diáspora
duplica e incluso triplica dicha cifra
sus mayores comunidades viven en rusia
eeuu y francia desde donde envían una
cantidad de remesas de gran importancia
para la economía armenia
latinoamérica los armenios forman
grandes comunidades en países como
uruguay o argentina en donde habitan en
torno a 80 mil armenios en la diáspora
para muchos de ellos turquía y
azerbaiyán son los enemigos eternos de
su nación
hoy es 24 de abril hay muchos pueblos
perseguidos pero es bonito que exista
este recuerdo para los armenios que
fueron perseguidos
los turcos deberían reconocer este
genocidio para que podamos avanzar y
vivir en paz
en turquía y azerbaiyán son dos países
diferentes pero hermanos que se
reconocen a sí mismos como un solo
pueblo y que se niegan a reconocer los
hechos de 1915 como un genocidio en la
esfera internacional 29 países reconocen
oficialmente al genocidio como tal
muchos otros evitan hacerlo para no
tener problemas diplomáticos con ankara